How could a moth possibly come out on top
in a dogfight with a bat?
A new study shows that moths aren’t exactly pushovers
when pitted against their nightly tormentors.
Researchers believe one of the reasons silk moths
in the Saturniidae family stand a fighting chance might
have something to do with the shape of their wings.
When it comes to hunting moths and
other flying insects, the most powerful tool in a bat’s
arsenal is its ability to use sonar
to pick targets out of the air.
However, researchers have found that the long,
elaborate tails on silk moth’s hindwings
help to deflect the bat’s sonar, like a built-in decoy.
Researchers found 4 distinct wing types related
to a silk moths’ ability to escape bat attacks
To test the effectiveness of each wing type,
they altered the profiles of three types of
silk moths to resemble the wing shapes.
They faced off the modified moths with
big brown bats in a flight room and captured the
results on high-speed cameras.
Researchers found that the larger the hindwing
and longer the tail, the better the moths’
chances of escaping bats on the hunt.
Since bats only eat a moth’s body and not its wings,
that’s what they look for when hunting.
The tails offer multiple body-like targets,
tricking striking bats.
And researchers say that the bats weren’t very effective
at finding a way around the moth’s defense.
Even after facing the same types of
hindwing shapes for months, bats still couldn’t tell
the difference between a tasty moth morsel
and its tail-driven decoy.
Score one for the underdog....
or... moth.